hello I'd like to introduce you to word
you may never heard before but you ought
to know
draw down draw down is a new way of
thinking about and acting on global
warming it's a goal for a future that we
want a future where reversing global
warming is possible
draw down is that point in time when
atmospheric concentrations of greenhouse
gases begin to decline on a year-to-year
basis more simply it's that point when
we take out more greenhouse gases than
we put in to Earth's atmosphere now I
know we're all concerned about climate
change but climate change is not the
problem
climate change is the expression of the
problem it's the feedback of the system
of the planet telling us what's going on
the problem is global warming provoked
by the increasing concentrations of
greenhouse gases caused by human
activity so how do we solve the problem
how do we begin the process of reversing
global warming the only way we know how
is to draw down to avoid putting
greenhouse gases up and to pull down
what's already there
I know given the current situation it
sounds impossible but humanity already
knows what to do we have real workable
technologies and practices that can
achieve drawdown and it's already
happening what we need is to accelerate
implementation and to change the
discourse from one of fear and confusion
which only leads to apathy to one of
understanding and possibility and
therefore opportunity I work for
organization called Project drawdown for
the last four years two
with a team of researchers and writers
from all over the world we've mapped
measured and detailed 100 solutions to
reversing global warming 80 already
exists today and when taken together
those 80 can achieve drawdown and 20 are
coming attraction solutions on the
pipeline and when they come online will
speed up our progress these are
solutions that are viable scalable and
financially feasible and they do one or
more of three things replace existing
fossil fuel based energy generation with
clean renewable sources reduce
consumption through technological
efficiency and behavior change and to
bio sequester carbon and our plants
biomass and soil store process we all
learn in grade school the magic of
photosynthesis it's through a
combination of these three mechanisms
that draw down becomes possible so how
do we get there well here's the short
answer this is a list of the top 20
solutions to reversing global warming
now I'll go into some detail but take a
few seconds to look over the list it's
eclectic I know from onshore wind
turbines to educating girls from plant
rich diets to rooftop solar technology
so let's break it down a little bit to
the right of the slide you'll see
figures in Giga tons or billions of tons
that represents the total equivalent
carbon dioxide reduced from the
atmosphere when the solution is
implemented globally over a 30-year
period now when we think about climate
solutions we often think about
electricity generation we think of
renewable energy as the most important
set of solutions and they are incredibly
important but the first thing to notice
about this list is the only five of the
top 20 solutions relate to electricity
what surprised
honestly was it eight of the top 20
relate to the food system
the climate impact of food may come as a
surprise to many people but what these
results show is that the decisions we
make every day about the food we produce
purchase and consume are perhaps the
most important contributions every
individual can make to reversing global
warming and how we manage land is also
very important protecting forests and
wetlands safeguards expands and creates
new carbon sinks that directly draw down
carbon this is how drawdown can happen
and only take food and Land Management
together twelve of the top 20 solutions
relate to how and why we use land this
fundamentally shifts traditional
thinking on climate solutions but let's
go to the top of the list because I
think what's there may also surprise you
the single most impactful solution
according to this analysis would be
refrigeration management or properly
managing and disposing of hydro
fluorocarbons also known as hf C's which
are used by refrigerant refrigerators
and air conditioners to cool the air we
did a great job with the Montreal
Protocol to limit the production of
chlorofluorocarbons CFCs because their
effect on the ozone layer but they were
replaced by HF C's which are hundreds to
thousands of times more potent a
greenhouse gas than carbon dioxide and
that 90 Giga tons reduced is a
conservative figure if we were to
account for the impact of the Kigali
agreement of 2016 which calls for the
phase-out of hydro fluorocarbons and
replaced them with natural refrigerants
which exist today this number could
increase to 120 to nearly 200 Giga tons
of avoided greenhouse gases
maybe you're surprised as we were now
before going into some details of
specific solutions you may be wondering
how we came to these calculations
well first of all we collected a lot of
data and we use statistical analysis to
create ranges that allow us to choose
reasonable choices for every input used
throughout the models and we chose a
conservative approach which underlies
the entire project all that data is
entered into the models ambitiously but
plausibly projected into the future and
compared against what we would have to
do anyway the 84 gigatonnes reduced from
onshore wind turbines for example
results from the electricity generated
from wind farms that would otherwise be
produced from coal or gas fire plants we
calculate all the costs to build and to
operate the plants and all the emissions
generated the same process is used to
compare recycling versus landfilling
regenerative versus industrial
agriculture protecting versus cutting
down our forests the results are then
integrated within and across systems to
avoid double counting and add it up to
see if we actually get to draw down ok
let's go into some specific solutions
rooftop solar comes in ranked number 10
when we picture rooftop solar in our
minds we often envision a warehouse in
Miami
covered in solar panels but these are
solutions that are relevant in urban and
rural settings high and low income
countries and they have cascading
benefits this is a family on a straw
island and lake titicaca receiving their
first solar panel before kerosene was
used for cooking and lighting kerosene
on a straw Island so by installing solar
this family is not only helping to
reduce emissions but providing safety
and security for their household and
tropical forests tell their own story
protecting currently degraded land in
the tropics and allowing natural
regeneration to occur is the number five
solution to reversing global warming
we can think of trees as giant sticks of
carbon this is draw down in action every
year as carbon is removed from the
atmosphere through photosynthesis which
converts carbon dioxide to plants
biomass and soil organic carbon and we
need to rethink how we produce our food
to make it more regenerative there are
many ways to do this and we researched
over 13 of them but these aren't new
ways of producing food they have been
practiced for centuries for four
generations but they are increasingly
displaced by modern agriculture which
promotes tillage mono cropping and the
use of in the use of synthetic
fertilizers and pesticides which degrade
the land and turn into a net emitter of
greenhouse gases regenerative
agriculture on the other hand restores
soil health and productivity increases
yield improves water retention then if
it smallholder farmers and large farming
operations alike and brings carbon back
to the land it's a win win win win win
it's not just how we produce food but
what we consume that has a massive
impact on global warming a plant rich
diet is not a vegan or a vegetarian diet
though I applaud any who make those
choices it's a healthy diet in terms of
how much we consume in particularly how
much meat is consumed in the richer
parts of the world we over consume
however in low-income countries show an
insufficient caloric and protein intake
that needs rebalancing and it's in the
rebalancing that a plant rich diet
becomes the number four solution to
reversing global warming
moreover approximately 1/3 of all food
produced is not eaten and wasted food
and it's an astounding eight percent of
global greenhouse gases we need to look
where process apply chain these losses
and wastage occurs in low-income
countries after
leaves the farm most food is wasted
early in a supply chain due to
infrastructure and storage challenges
foods not wasted by consumers in
low-income countries which struggle to
feed their population in the developed
world instead after fruit leaves the
farm most food is wasted at the end of
the supply chain by markets and
consumers and wasted food ends up in a
landfill where it emits methane and eco
as it decomposes this is a consumer
choice problem it's not a technology
issue preventing food waste from the
beginning is the number three solution
but here's the interesting thing when we
look at the food system as a whole and
we implement all the production
solutions like regenerative agriculture
and we adopt a plant rich diet and we
reduce food waste our research shows
that we would produce enough food on
current farmland to feed the world's
growing population a healthy
nutrient-rich diet now until 2050 and
beyond that means we don't need to cut
down forests for food production the
solutions to reversing global warming
are the same solutions to food
insecurity now a solution that often
does not get talked enough about family
planning by providing men and women the
right to choose when how and if to raise
a family through reproductive health
clinics and education access to
contraception and freedom devoid of
persecution can reduce the estimated
global population by 2050 that reduced
population means reduced demand for
electricity food travel buildings and
all other resources all the energy and
emissions that are used to produce that
higher demand is reduced by providing
the basic human right to choose when how
an if to raise a family but family
planning cannot happen without equal
quality of education to girls currently
being denied access
now we've taken the small liberty here
because the impact of universal
education and family planning research
resources are so inextricably
intertwined that we chose to cut it
right down the middle but taken together
educating girls and family planning is
the number one solution to reversing
global warming reducing approximately
120 billion tons of greenhouse gases so
it's drawdown possible the answer is yes
it is possible but we need all 80
solutions there are no silver bullets or
subsets of solutions that are going to
get us there the top solutions will take
us far along the pathway but there's no
such thing as a small solution we need
all 80 but here's the great thing we
would want to implement these solutions
whether or not global warming was even a
problem because they have cascading
benefits to human and Planetary
well-being renewable electricity results
in clean abundant access to energy for
all plant rich diet reduce food waste
results in a healthy global population
with enough food and sustenance family
planning and educating girls this is
about human rights about gender equality
this is about economic improvement and
the freedom of choice it's about justice
regenerative agriculture managed grazing
agroforestry silvopasture restore soil
health benefits farmers and brings
carbon back to the land protecting our
ecosystems also protects biodiversity
and safeguards planetary health and the
oxygen that we breathe it's tangible
benefits to all species is in calcul but
one last point because I know it's
probably on everybody's mind how much is
this going to cost well we asked to me
to implement all 80 solutions would cost
about 29 trillion dollars over 30 years
that's just about a trillion a year now
I know that sounds like a lot but we
have to remember that global GDP is over
80 trillion every year and the estimated
savings from implementing these
solutions is 74 trillion dollars over
double the costs that's a net savings of
44 trillion dollars so drawdown as
possible we can do it if we want to it's
not going to cost that much and the
return on investment that investment is
huge here's the Welcome surprise when we
implement these solutions we shift the
way we do business from a system that is
inherently exploitative and extractive
to a new normal that is by nature
restorative and regenerative we need to
rethink our global goals to move beyond
sustainability towards regeneration and
along the way reverse global warming
thank you
[Applause]